e
uh so thank you one uh one and all we
will open up our uh Capital project
overview committee um at this time I
can't see the clock there uh welcome
welcome those present uh for being here
today Commissioners and so thank you um
I would like to uh start with acceptance
2024 motion's been moved and seconded
all those in favor signify by saying I I
and he opposed uh motion carries
unanimous uh we have no old business new
business I believe we have a couple uh
items on
informational and I believe we also have
another guest that would like to speak
with us so um I would like to welcome uh
commissioner uh environmental
services and uh I'm excited to read what
you had submitted and if you have a few
it uh good morning uh so uh I I'll
briefly speak but I have uh our
assistant Commissioner Adam crepo and
Phil trobridge who uh is leading our our
charge on uh some of our database
efforts uh but uh as we presented last
time uh we're pleased to be able to make
progress uh on the uh the uh both uh our
internal but also probably more
importantly our external uh database
work uh to help serve our constituents
so uh we're pleased with the the funds
we've been able to get uh from the
legislature and arpa uh and uh we uh we
feel we're making the best use of those
possible and we hope you agree so if
that's all right with you I'm probably
not going to ask them to sit in the same
chair but uh maybe the the Phil and Adam
you good morning thanks for having us
this morning um so in October as you
mentioned chairman uh we submitted some
updates on our technology projects um we
you know we're here today to provide you
know brief explanation some and take
some questions uh before I dive into
specifics I just I thought it would be
helpful to let you know we have two
capital appropri ations and one from
arpa um and so throughout all of these
projects we've been trying to spend the
arpa funding down first as many of you
know the deadlines around arpa um it
needs to be obligated by the end of this
year and spent by the end of 2026 and so
there's a little bit more of a of a
pressing deadline for for those funds um
you know as as most of you know
historically for most permit
applications we've had to applicants had
to file paper forms and um and we're
using these these Appropriations from
arpa and Capitol really to to make
transformational progress on getting our
forms in our land resources management
uh section online and so that includes
alteration of terrain um Shoreland
subsurface as as you know chairman and
um and
uh Wetlands so
since January we've we've received
nearly 3,000 total submissions online uh
We've made a lot of progress over the
last year uh like I said a year ago we
didn't have any forms uh in those
programs online and uh we've gotten all
of wetlands and all of shorland which
accepts the most applications uh by far
in in the Department of Environmental
Services from from per uh permites so
that's that's that's a huge
accomplishment there um but what we're
also planning to do and that's it's
that's through enform um it's a windsor
Solutions product and so what we're
doing next is we're working with Windsor
on a on another uh project to this is
really eiling and bringing e permitting
online which is being basically being
able to file everything with without
really having the submit PDFs except for
plans and things like that uh right now
they're able to submit a PDF of their
application and some some you know basic
information in the in the form of you
know name address phone number those
that sort of thing currently um and so
we're we're expecting to do that over
the next two two or three years to get
to get all of those um online and what
that will also do is um replace all of
our Legacy databases and so we have a
lot of Legacy databases in lrm uh that
that will
basically take us from having to accept
those online and enter them in uh on the
back end to allowing someone to submit
something online and have that go right
straight into the database and um it it
really creates creates efficiencies for
us on the back end but also for the
applicant on the front end and and
hopefully uh reduce reduce turnaround
times um the next effort I'd like to
just give a quick update on is our
subsurface digitization efforts um we
we are digitizing around 4 million uh
old subsurface files those are all of
our septic um historic sep septic
records uh from 1967 until around 2015
2015 we started to to do things uh you
know in the 21st century so um you know
we're about 15% through that total
project um and it's really helping
constituents already we've we've gotten
a lot of feedback Rec especially
recently that folks are using this data
to see you know what how old their
septic system is and and historically
they've had to call in and staff have
had to actually go physically find the
find the folder or the the box that it's
sitting in and whether it's in a
warehouse or physically at 29 Hazen
Drive where we are and uh and sip
through those and so this will create
some efficiencies there as well as
allowing ease for the public to actually
go online and find this stuff when when
they're uh whether it's a real estate
transaction or or they're developing a
new property um so with that I mean
those are those are really the the major
updates since uh I believe the last time
we spoke was in in June um but but happy
to take any questions and and we have
Phil trobridge here in our land
resources management section that um Can
can help speak to some of the finer
details as well thank you commission
crpo
questions I have a couple I missed a
point when you were speaking did you say
the majority the you have the higher
higher percentage of your applications
or Shoreland is that what you said
Shoreland and wetlands yeah um th that's
by far the most applications we receive
in the department it's in the thousands
um roughly 3,000 I
believe okay it's and subsurfaces how
many subsurface 6000 6,000 subsurface
okay if I if I could follow up you
wouldn't mind so um this whole process
is phenomenal the um um personally we
file a lot of shorel a lot of uh
subsurface applications but it's really
exciting the shorelands moving forward
that's tremendous a lot less trips to
the printer for me to generate plans to
send them to you um has there been
energy and and perhaps Phil I should be
speaking to him has there been energy to
expand the uh limits on the shorel by
the pbn process I I've seen people
getting much more comfortable with this
there's a there's a finite 900 square
feet for a new structure is there is
there an effort to Ink that up some get
us up another 10 15% I'll I'll uh let
Bill come up and speak to that if if
good morning chairman makoni and members
of the committee um regarding your
question represent woni the Shoreland
rules are up for read-option next year
so we are looking at all those rules in
terms and any kind of streamlining we
can do with the the by notification
process we'll by all means do uh we're
doing a lot more of that with the
Wetland side we're doing a big uh push
on the Wetland rules right now uh and
there there's an effort there to to uh
try and uh have more permit by
notifications and also just a more
streamlined process overall thank you
for that is there a conversation ongoing
conversation about increasing the
thresholds a legitimate conference
happening on that
conversation from 900 square feet to a
higher number and 1500 to 1,800 or some
somewhere in there uh we haven't been
discussing that as of yet but it is
something I can bring up and bring into
the convers
okay thank you thank you gentlemen any
other
you item two would be the Community
College uh system in New Hampshire is
there someone here to speak to that and
I appreciate the report that you sent
along uh detailing a lot of your
information and as always I I stand next
to you with Community College program
it's
invaluable press a press a button
you was is there anything else you
wanted to highlight about your report
sir do you want me to just go to
questions you can go to questions I sure
because well I don't know if Chris
explained um I apologize I thought
I was filling out corer reports for uh
Das and um there was some confusion I
thought that was the quarter of the
report that came here Chris yes so as
you might recall last meeting I had
indicated that the Community College had
been providing information as part of
the report that dis collects on capital
projects however in the capital budget
the committee the legislature had asked
for more specific details on the items
related to the critical maintenance and
the it work at the uh community college
so they are following up but it was just
an oversight it wasn't an intentional um
you know disregard for what the note
said that the Community College thought
they metant what was being asked for
after talking with them they agreed that
they could provide this report it would
be better to meet the language thank you
any questions the
committee
repr thank you uh thank you thank you
for your time
a nice
report the um I believe
um swfit you would like
to yes Charles
Char STW at oh please yes
welcome Mr Hunter good morning good
morning Charles Hunter assistant vice
president government affairs with Jen
and Wyoming Railroads uh we own the St
Lawrence and Atlantic railroad up in the
North Country um wanted to report that
we were successful in the last round of
the Federal Railroad administration's
Chrissy grant program New Hampshire do
was a big part of us being successful in
this round of Grants by providing
$500,000 in matching funds um over the
years the the Committees especially
Public Works has
supported uh kind of buying this one
piece at a time over many years I've
been around this railroad since the
mid90s and we've been replacing the
older rail with a heavier rail to get up
to the modern 286,000 PB rail car
standard for North America and with this
matching funds of
$500,000 we were able to get a u a
project worth 19.5 million with some
matching funds from Main
do uh the railroad and the Federal
Railroad Administration so this is
really a big deal um we're able to get a
notice proceed from the Federal Railroad
Administration go actually buy the rail
which we bought this year this summer we
we dropped the rail it's on the ground
in Coos County U we've got to get our
agreements in place we've got the draft
agreement from New Hampshire do right
now we're going over we have to get an
agreement with the Federal Railroad
Administration as well but our plans are
to install this rail next year along
with some switches uh a couple of grade
Crossings some ancillary supporting work
so this is a big deal for this railroad
it's it's been in the works for many
years uh a big collaboration between New
Hampshire Maine and Vermont to get this
done and uh that's my
report thank you um 286 pound is that
for is that 286,000 lbs so that's the
the gross load of the
commodity plus the car thank
you work well done thank you thank you
any any
questions thank you sir for taking the
time to come to see us yes sir the um
Lou I just wanted are you here for long
term also yes okay thank you I'll save
so with that I I um
um this committee will be coming to a
close with a um new committee to be
formed uh next session so there's no
need to set a meeting at this point in
time and uh is there any other business
before the
committee I will move to adjourn then
I thank you all for coming